durch einen freund und willkommen zurück
beim mittlerweile glaube ich fünfter
part von entropa wir haben vorhin eine
optik eine optische aua eine optische
illusion feststellen können dass da ich
noch mal ganz kurz zurück um euch das
kurz zu zeigen hier den zuschauern
das war echt interessant aus und zwar
lade dich lade dich lade dich los er
wolle sich nicht lädt jedenfalls ist
diese komplette map ziemlich ziemlich
ziemlich ziemlich cool aufgebaut muss
ich bisher sagen die websense voller die
pumpkins motion auf jeden fall passt ja
da hinten ist die kiste springt ist und
ich fähig bin dran vorbei nicht ab hat
noch game oder und ich hab gar nicht
bleibt man kurz einer von euch da damit
wird solchen teleportieren können und
damit wir da immer dann das bett setzen
können
das war ein bisschen fällig zudem kann
ich mich jetzt teleportieren wäre es
wäre es mir yusen lösen hat einen großen
busen hallo so von allem was ich schaffe
das jetzt daran zu springen ich hab's
geschafft
ach so ich brauche geld als anwältin
danach hier
ich brauche jetzt erst mal darüber zu
springen
nach sondern ihr uns bonder habt dann
passt das
kommt ihr toll gesprungen
es sieht echt cool aus das ist
mittlerweile ein badezimmer aber auf den
kopf wer am bett oder den kindern oder
kinderzimmer ja es stimmt kinderzimmer
genau interessant
trinken macht es einfach
ich würde ihnen gezeugt importiert also
in die zweite web design schon wieder
draußen stellt die ganze zeit zurück
teleportiert verstehen nicht schlags und
jetzt hab' ich geschafft ist geschafft
so einfach hier weiter laufen wo seid
ihr den pumpkins teilerfolgen du warst
auch da kommt so ganz scharfe kurve
scharfe kurve
ich hab's geschafft
ich denke schon wieder legen welches bei
der webs drin los los sagt okay wo sind
denn die anderen zwei da bleibt wo man
hin muss
ich bin jetzt hier bei grün darüber
geschafft habe ich über gesprungen zum
kind dann noch weiter da sind weiter
aufgehe und hier dann so ein bisschen
versetzt hier sind
komm zu mir kommen zur preisverleihung
hallo ich hab's geschafft bin stolz auch
echt genial aus hier nicht alles wenn
ich mal sagen ein großes großes ein
großes großes kompliment an dem web
erstelle ich genial
das ist erst weiter dann ist es fast so
wie unsere aufnahme weil habt ihr den
diamanten
was sollte ich jetzt sagen das fass
sowie eine aufnahme bei wait till de
10/6 eine optische illusion
ich komme ja aber man muss warten bis
das gelautet ist ich warte mal ganz
gesetz ist wahrscheinlich wie diese
endlose treppe da ja ich möchte mir das
mal komplett angucken
das ist krass
echt interessant aus ich mache ich bin
hier nur um screenshots machen weil es
einfach so witzig aussieht
ich hoffe dass ich schaffe es nicht doch
ich hab sogar bei während der aufnahme
keine ahnung ich habe die macht der mode
so ich bin oben oder sieht so aus als
wäre hier irgendwas ich fühle mich
gerade wie auch so einen lsd trip ich
sehe ich schon da hinten was man jetzt
machen muss mal ein bett holen
ich glaube ja
die first online ich möchte mich an
deine füße legen muss mein bett ich lege
wieder in der wand von menschen
ich bin total sauer wiederum mensch ein
bisschen leichter finde ich nicht
fliegen mit dem game mode a-ha steckte
das ist jetzt anders
adam wo bist du und ich fliege und ich
und teleportiert
ich hab's gerechtigkeit schaffen hier
nicht wenn man versteht great wheel of
the night was drüber schauen und
gegenübers eine straße und auf der
straße musste folgen
ich hab's geschafft irgendwie ich weiß
nicht wie unbedingt gestorben ich weiß
nicht warum form habe ich es geschafft
das frage ich mich gerade er ihre musik
wie in dem leser portal bleiben
man darf sie nicht verlassen dann
fordert sich rechtzeitig weg ich mach
das mal hat die für die zuschauer sonst
nicht kontrast aus haben wir einen
checkpoint vergessen aufzumachen kann es
ehrlich ich bin hier und hab den
diamanten auch wenn ich meinen augen
will es vor dem trip tor gelandet wäre
das halte ich dann blöd ich finde aber
gerade nicht den ausgang irgendwie
heraus
hallo
ich habe keine ahnung was mit der map
als ob ich mit euch reden macht sie
fertig würde interessieren was passiert
wenn ich jetzt hier in etwa gehe ob der
nette aktiviert ich glaube schon
ich hoffe ich probiere es einfach mal
ich manchmal die diamanten unten hin als
irgendwas passiert etwa ausgemacht
wahrscheinlich ist dass sogar die tür
zum nächsten level dieser netter portal
wo sonst ist hier nämlich nichts aber
der partys ein paar minuten vorbei von
da also in kanada das jeder auch
unterkommt es überlebte
ich weiß ich bin durch die portale durch
doch nicht anders ja einfach durch die
portale also wie soll ich das
beschreiben ihr seht ihr die strecke
diese fahrbahn da auf der einen seite
diese graue wolle dinge sind da genauso
angeordnet ist auch dieses dieses ob sie
dieses portal dingens und ihr müsst ich
sag mal genauso wie die straße halt wie
das da oben steht an den schildern
ersten das überlebt weiß ich selber
nicht
hast du ein game morgen stimmt ich hatte
gainward noch an dass das kann sein dass
ich das überlebt ja keine ahnung meint
ist kein wasser
ich würde sagen man einfach jetzt und
dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten folge
bei gaming pc fünf im rat sechster